Hello there.
Before we crack open this
one, I thought I should
just let you know that we
started a second channel
last week, and you should
click here to subscribe,
and definitely watch the
first video on the channel,
Dan Gets Wet.
And now we'll crack on
with the flame thrower.
Where he gets the opposite of wet.
Hello there the internet, I'm Gavin.
You may immediately be wondering,
where is Dan, and why am I
holding a fire extinguisher?
Here's the answer to both questions.
Yes kids, this is a flame thrower.
And if you can't tell, I've got a
huge grin under this.
I can tell.
You can tell.
I can see it in hour eyes.
They really all scrunched.
You have grin eyes.
All right, cool.
So thanks to X Matter for this personal
flame throwing kit.
By the way, first time I've ever received
a flame thrower in the post.
Ah, it's not my first time.
What?
Nah, nah.
It happened once before.
Just one of those or what?
That can hold 12 gallons?
12 1/2 liters
You can drown Roger Rabbit in that.
It's quite a pretty color.
Yeah, it's nice, isn't it?
Didn't realize that diesel was green.
I'm really hot in this suit,
but, we're about to get hotter.
Whoa!
Things are about to heat up in here.
First rule die.
If you think that looked like the most fun
you'd ever have in your life,
then you're wrong.
It's more fun than that.
So it's more fun then the most fun
you could have in your life.
I'm not the most intelligent bloke.
On the southern rise,
anything is possible.
I had a really good time filming that.
When I was downwind from
it and it was coming at me.
I had a great time firing
it out there to be fair.
I'm wearing shorts.
All I could do, I was aiming for ya,
I was like, here we go.
Fired it, and it was
just a big wall of flame.
And then, I was like.
I should have just
legged it while the flame
blows out, so when it cleared there
would just be no one there.
I think it would have been like, sweet.
Took care of him finally.
Yes.
Hopefully, you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us
on Twitter and bad share,
and most importantly of all, subscribe to
the Slow Mo Guys channel.
And then tell every
single person you know.
Like all 300 people.
3, all right.
I don't think I know 300 people.
I think you got like, 6 friends, maybe.
I've got like 6 good friends,
ya I know some people.
I've got acquaintances.
No
Wait, are we friends?
I'm one of the 6, I think.
You're one of the 6?
Which means you got 5 other friends.
All right, we'll see
you in the next video.
Thanks to Audible for
sponsoring this video,
they've got over a 180,000
audio books available.
With things like autobiographies
to Game of Thrones,
by George R. R. Martin.
Which I'm currently
relistening to and reliving,
as you can see, getting
ready for the new season.
If you like the show, you'll
love listening to the books.
There's more characters,
more, ya know what,
I'm slacking off.
Whew.
There's more story lines,
it's really involved in destiny really.
It's fantastic.
If you'd like a free trial at Audible,
just follow the link in
the description below.
Audible.com/slowmo
and you're set.
But enough of that,
for the North.